Many landowners and homeowners around Wyoming
choose chemicals to help them manage weeds
and insects around their properties.
Chemicals can be used effectively when we
manage them effectively.
One of the things we want to think about when
managing chemicals is storage.
The first thing we want to think about is
limiting access.
We don’t want humans and animals to interact
with this unless they need to, especially
youth, children, we want to keep them away
from chemicals.
One of the things we really want to focus
on when managing chemicals is the label.
The label is going to tell us how toxic a
chemical is, what the chemical’s used for,
and how to store it.
So, the University of Wyoming has a fact sheet
online at the University of Wyoming Extension webpage.
It has 15 focus points to think about and
to utilize when storing chemicals.
You know, it talks about storing chemicals
by category.
We want our insecticides in a different place
than our herbicides.
We want to certainly keep all chemicals in
their original containers.
We certainly don’t ever want to see them
in food containers or anything like that.
And the last thing we probably want to think
about is not to store our personal protective
equipment, our gloves, our glasses, the things
that we’re thinking about keeping us safe
from chemicals.
We want to store them in a different place.
If you have more questions, you can certainly
look at that fact sheet online.
This is Hudson Hill with the University of
Wyoming Extension.
You’re watching From the Ground Up.